-Did you guys see the picture of
French President Emmanuel Macron
that was going around yesterday?
It went viral because his shirt
is unbuttoned
and he's showing
a lot of chest hair.
Here it is.
Here it is right -- Yeah.
[ Audience laughs, oohs ]
Well, Macron is running for
re-election right now
and he actually asked us
if he could premiere
a new campaign song
on our show tonight.
So ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome French President
Emmanuel Macron.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ [ French accent ]
Bonjour, it is me ♪
♪ With my chest hair, you see ♪
♪ Do you think I'm sexy? ♪
♪ I sure hope you say oui ♪
♪ I have good policies
for ze economy ♪
♪ I shall make my VP
Emily in Paris ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm as French as can be ♪
♪ I can get you in free ♪
♪ To ze patisserie ♪
♪ The chef is ratatouille ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ We can nibble ze brie,
smoke a cig by the sea ♪
♪ Give my chest hair a squeeze
as it blows in ze breeze ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Now I must say adieu ♪
♪ But in 2022 ♪
♪ If you all vote for me ♪
♪ I will whisper merci ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ But for now I bid you
adieu, adieu, adieu ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show tonight!
Marlon Wayans is here!
Natasha Lyonne is here.
And we got music
from Dove Cameron.
We are playing "True
Confessions" when we come back.
Stick around, everyone.
♪♪